Google has a better sense of what we prefer than we do.
And Google certainly has a better sense of what we prefer than
our partners, too.
I, I can vouch for that in my marriage.
You know,
these algorithms are going to start making more and more of these decisions.
Why did my watch just tell me to stand? You know, we,
we've basically giving up our agency company.
Really one of the big, uh,
precursors to solving these problems in many ways is a restoration of trust.
Jack.
I believe that universal basic income is central to a restoration of trust.
Hello,
welcome to another episode of yang speaks where I sit down for a fascinating
conversation with the co-founder and CEO of both Twitter
and square Jack Dorsey.
Jack's one of the most profound thinkers on what the heck is coming next
in the world. And so we talked about the future of work,
mindfulness, universal basic income, of course,
one of my favorite subjects in the world.
How is data owned and shared what he's concerned about for the future,
what he would suggest to the president, the future of small business,
and after all of that, there's a really big announcement at the end.
So stay tuned for my sit-down conversation virtually of course,
with Jack Dorsey,
Pleasure and privilege to welcome to yang speaks the one,
the only CEO of both Twitter and square and co-founder
of both Mr. Jack Dorsey. Jack. Welcome. Thank you. So, Jack,
I don't know if you remember this, I've been waiting to see you to ask you this,
but you and I met briefly six years ago in Detroit.
You spoke at this Techonomy conference and I met you
backstage very briefly.
So I just wanted to take a trip down memory lane and say,
you might not remember this, but I was like Jack Dorsey back in 2014.
I remember now you seem like such an elevated human. Uh,
you also look the part kind of to,
you have like this sense of Jack from the future. Um, you have that,
and I think part of it is that, um, you meditate,
uh,
you're mindful like you take this stuff very seriously about like awareness of
your own, um, health surroundings.
And I think it gives you like a connectivity to, um,
like the, the world at large,
in a way that many people don't necessarily experience. Uh,
but when I, uh, want to clear my head,
one of the things I do is try and get away from Twitter for a period of
time. And I know you have techniques that you use to try and, uh,
be more mindful. Uh,
one thing I'm curious about is whether any of the tools or techniques you use
utilize technology.
And do you think that there's a way that technology can actually make us more
mindful and aware as opposed to, uh, possibly the opposite?
I, I do. I mean, I think, um,
mindfulness and meditation for me is a practice of, um,
honing your skills of observation and making sure that we,
um, are present and aware of all,
everything that we're doing and that we're not blindly reacting to it and
just falling into a hole, but we're fully aware of the what,
and also the why behind it and able to make choices differently.
So I've structured a lot of my work around, um, this concept of like,
how do I get, how do I focus more on one thing?
And most of my day is actually spent on,
on this iPhone here.
And the reason I use this instead of a computer is there's only one app open
at a time. So I, I definitely take my walks.
I definitely, um, meditate without a device and whatnot,
but I think it's more about how we train our minds to, um,
to, uh, to really observe it to, um, you've,
you've Al's book 21 lessons for 2020 first century. Um,
I think is phenomenal. His last chapter, his last lesson,
the 21st lesson is around meditation. He believes,
and I think we all feel this right now that, um,
Google has a better sense of what we prefer than we do.
And Google certainly has a better sense of what we prefer than
our partners.
I can vouch for that in my marriage.
Thank you, your kids. I mean,
Google will have a better sense of even who they are than they might.
And his recommendation is a practice of meditation actually
helps us understand why we're doing the things that we're doing,
why we react in the ways that we do.
And it's important for us to have that base level understanding and
self-awareness, um,
because otherwise we're just off shooting every single decision to these
algorithms. And then who are we? I mean, it's, it's the,
it's the Wall-E future that one of my favorite Pixar movies that, you know,
that that is a future where we're headed to. And, um, I,
I think meditation is one of those tools that,
that can at least make us aware of the choices that we're making.
Agency towards technology. Uh, that that's certainly like a massive,
uh, issue because I do have kids and to the extent that we had screen time
limits gone out the window with the COVID crisis, I have no idea how much,
how much time they're spending. Um,
so you just talked about how Google might know me better than my partner.
You've talked about how you're concerned about also the future of data
ownership. Um, and I, and it's like, I feel like with square,
you're privy to a certain form of data though.
It's much more business oriented than, um, you know,
people's like browsing habits and the rest of.
Yeah. I mean, it just, just a high level principle. We, we,
people need their own, their own data.
And I think the technology to allow that to happen across
service lines across company lines did not exist until recently with the
blockchain and things that blockchain presents a new opportunity for us to
create identity wallets for people. Um,
and then you get to choose what,
what services get to read from it and also get to write from it.
And you can turn that off at any time. I think it's,
it's one of those ideas that, that needs to happen as quickly as possible.
And that leads to so many other beneficial things in our space.
That's tremendous that that is a beautiful vision where we
actually own our data. And then there are various companies that, uh,
can make use of it with our permission. And we, yeah,
and we can turn it off at will. Um,
like that would be a whole different level of agency for us,
because right now, again, I, you know,
you don't know really what the heck is going on, um,
in terms of your data getting sold and resold packaged and repackaged.
And, you know, what's interesting is like, I get a sense,
a lot of the tech companies themselves, they may not know.
That's true. That's true. I mean, this is, this is hard. This is hard stuff.
I think the most important companies to actually make this happen are the folks
that are actually deploying hardware,
because I think it has to happen when you buy a device. When you buy a laptop,
when you buy a phone, when you buy a tablet,
if I start on Android and I moved to Apple,
ideally all these things cross-connect connect just one wallet. Um,
but I do think it's,
it's up to the larger companies to actually make it work together and make this
a standard. Um, and then I hope they do.
And that's where I think smart regulation could come in, um,
in order to push them to do something.
That is one of the frustrations I have too,
where government has been absent from most all of these issues for
years and decades, uh,
where our legislators have a very dim understanding of most technology.
Um, we all saw when, uh, when Mark Zuckerberg testified to Congress,
they were asking him all these inane questions about Facebook, its operation.
And you were like, what are you talking? Like,
like it wasn't like a surprise visit. You know what I mean?
They like theoretically knew he was coming and could prepare.
So let's imagine for a, that, um, I were present in the United States and,
uh, you and I were talking and you were like, well,
thank goodness that happened, Andrew. Um,
here are like the three things I really wish that the government could
intelligently, uh, get involved with. That would be a massive help to us.
And let's agree that universal basic income is one of them and that's happened.
And, you know, that's related to technology,
but not necessarily an intrinsically a tech issue.
Like what are the top few things that you wish an intelligent government
government could help with? I'd imagine AI is probably somewhere on that list.
AI is definitely on that list. And I think like when I,
when I talked to global leaders and regulators around the world, they're,
they're focused on the outcomes instead of the primitives being used to build
these technologies,
we have to focus our regulation around the primitives being used and how things
are built rather than just putting band-aids over the outcomes. You know,
these algorithms are going to start making more and more of these decisions and
they're not being built in such way that it's required,
that they explain why that would be one. You know,
one simple piece of regulation is a,
it's a field of research in AI called explainability really hard to do,
but even small steps we take there would be meaningful.
Why did my watch just tell me to stand? You know, just, just,
it's just basic things because we're offloading more and more of our decisions
to these algorithms. And like you've all said in his book,
if we don't understand why we're doing it and why they're making these
decisions, we've just, you know,
we we've basically giving up our agency completely.
Why did I turn left? Just that.
Exactly. Also when we think of AI, where we go, the algorithms,
but more important is the data. And it,
it's very hard for a startup right now to build a
compelling AI algorithm without access to massive
amounts of data, which are owned by very, very few companies right now, Google,
Facebook, Amazon, Apple.
Apparently the public sector has vast troves of data that are not being made
available to commercial actors like Twitter or even
academics. Uh, this is one thing that I know we could, uh,
help with very quickly where the public sector governments are sitting on like
traffic patterns to whether to like, uh, you know,
to like a soil quality.
Like there are things that we could do that companies could do if they had more
access. Yeah.
And, and now, and, and I think that brings to another point is like, if,
if you were president, I would ask you like, how, how do we,
how do we establish a stronger partnership between technology
companies and government and NGOs and the media,
because all four of these have a significant part to play in how
society functions and there's faults in
every single one of them right now. And, um, all of our institutions,
companies, media government have lost a lot of our trust and that can be very
isolating and it's very hard to solve problems with death and it could be
destructive. Yeah. So I,
I guess those are the three things I would ask.
The, the rebuilding of trust is something I'm very passionate about Jack,
because, you know, you can just look at the polling and see that our trust in,
like you said, media, government, financial institutions, uh,
schools, uh, hospitals, probably pre crisis.
I think our trust has probably gone up the most trusted institution in American
life right now. I believe it's still the U S military, uh, like the, like the,
the presidency it's collapsed and that that's pre-Trump. And so to me,
one of the big, uh,
precursors to solving these problems in many ways is a restoration of trust. Um,
and so if you have these institutions that have been failing us in many,
many regards, uh, for a long time, it's hard to then say, okay,
that institution has been failing me for a long time, but now I trust it again.
Yeah.
Exactly. I, and I think we are, we have to decompose trust,
like how do you earn trust in the first place?
I think transparency is one way to RNM. I think, um, uh,
accountability is another way to earn it.
I think reliability and being dependent is another way to earn it,
but there's, there's a, there's a matrix of ways to earn trust and they,
they need to be ranked and they need to, um, they,
they need to be applied to all these institutions, but more importantly,
to connections between the institutions.
I think that is what's failing us the most right now.
Everyone is just so isolated.
Your idea of a partnership between government media tech
companies, and NGOs is profound. We should a hundred percent do that.
One thing I, I heard a lot from, uh, um, Joe,
Sindo the prime minister of New Zealand. Um, and,
and this was right after the Christ church call. Um, um,
so like she, you know, she, she also was trying to push like,
this is not just the government or tech technology companies.
This is the media too. Yeah. A lot of,
a lot of the videos being shared on, on Twitter after that,
we're not, you know, we we're, we're not individuals on Twitter.
They were actually reporters on Twitter, even though just into,
in prime minister, Jacinta in the country, he asked those not to be shared.
So we have to collaborate more. Um, otherwise, you know,
everything that we're, we're going to be facing will just not work.
You know, Jack,
I believe that universal basic income is central to a restoration of trust.
Uh, where if a society actually invests in you in a way and says, Hey, look,
here's money. Um,
then you actually become more trusting and optimistic where you're like, okay,
like you actually do value me, care about me.
You'll invest in me. And my future.
You'll invest in my kids and my future because people can tell when you're
bullshitting them, honestly, it's like, if you say to them, Hey, you're great.
Like you're a citizen. It's important. Um, they're like, you know,
like young people at this point, I'm like, yeah, but if you're like, Hey,
you're important. We'd love you and here's money.
And we're not even going to tell you what to do with it. Like we trust you.
We love you. Um, that's actually a game changer. I can't tell you Jack,
like I randomly like Venmo someone money. Um,
and I know you've done the same thing, like, like on Twitter, but I use cash app
use cash app. It's the future.
I did Venmo. And you know, I'm, I'm not gonna lie. So other competitors do,
it's all good. As long as we bring in money, that's great.
As long as they got the money. Um,
but just like the act of someone receiving money, it's like,
they can't believe it. Um, and just like when our government, you know,
even sent those $1,200 checks,
like no one believed it until it was in their account. Um,
like really there's so much, uh,
built up distrust and skepticism that when you
actually get that money,
like it diffuses it it's about to me actually restoring trust in
people, humanity, our society, our way of life,
the fact that we actually care about each other. I mean, I,
I live by the principle of everything is connected. So if someone is in pain,
I'm in pain ultimately over time.
And I want to make sure that I'm doing whatever I can in my lifetime to,
to help that through my company's works through my own personal, um,
giving, um,
in I'm in a situation that I never imagined when I was a kid or when I was 25,
or I didn't have any aspect of what money would mean
until I was probably 35. And I just,
I I'm so grateful.
But part of gratitude is not just saying, I'm grateful.
It's doing it. Gratitude through action, man,
made that be like the theme of this era.
All right. If you're listening to this,
you're obviously a fan of podcasts and one of the best podcasts out there is the
Jordan harbinger show. It's an Apple top 50 podcasts.
It's one of Apple's best 2018 podcasts and well, and we love it.
It's got a frankly,
a range of topics ranging from talking to FBI negotiators about how to deal with
hostage situations. Um, you've got mental health situations.
You've got Tony Hawk on there.
You've got such wide range of topics and Jordan's such a fascinating guy.
So it's not pop psychology or superficial advice or BS,
inspirational nonsense.
It's a show that offers meaningful fun life-changing insights with a practical
edge.
And I love the worksheets cause I come away with like what I'm supposed to do
from an episode like this. Um, and there's no BS.
It's very straightforward and simple for someone like that.
Yeah, it's really good listening. Good learning, uh,
good information from experts that you kinda wish you had access to.
And now Jordan's done it for you.
Check out the Jordan harbinger show on Jordan harbinger.com/subscribe on
Apple, Spotify, wherever you get your podcasts.
I, it seems to me like you were actually ahead of me in universal basic income.
It's not like you need an Andrew Yang, Andrew Yang. Um,
we'd love to hear from you as to like how you originally were exposed to it over
the past number of years and how you became such a staunch believer and champion
of it over the, over the past few years,
just seeing everything happening with AI and specifically
in square. Um, we, you know,
we serve sellers and their employees are cashiers and we can
see the writing on the wall in terms of the need for people behind those,
those cashiers. We saw this when we had an app called caviar,
which is a free delivery,
which is basically moving the point of sale to the customer's hand.
Um,
the restaurants don't need someone managing the cashier anymore if they shift to
a more, more delivery. Um, and we, we see that throughout,
um, the business and that, um, you know, we,
we, we talk a lot about the, we talk a lot about the self-driving trucks, uh,
and, and whatnot. And this is even coming for programming.
Like a lot of the goals of machine learning and deep learning is to write the
software itself over time.
So a lot of entry level programming jobs will just not be as relevant anymore.
So every single field is going to be touched by automation and
UBI. To me represented a floor,
the floor that people could stand on, um,
and really have the, the knowledge and peace of mind,
ultimately that they could survive and eat and feed their
children while they are learning how to transition into this new
world. It doesn't mean that they don't work.
It means that they have a floor with which to,
to build and to, um,
get to a skill stack that would be, um,
more relevant in this, in this future.
So I think that's one aspect of it.
And I think D the only way we answer these questions is your
experimentation. Yeah.
So, so Jack, that's where we connected while I was running for president,
that I was like, you very,
very concerned about the impact of automation and technology,
and you were closer to it than obviously just about anybody.
And one of the things I've been saying is that this pandemic,
this crisis is accelerating the rate of change that we had expected,
where I've been saying we're seeing 10 years of progress or change in 10 weeks.
Uh, and is that similar to what you've seen in what you,
what you've seen companies investing in?
Oh, yeah. I mean, like, just on the square side,
just the shift towards online has been a,
has been break fast and like, it's, uh,
it's just been incredible to see how people are,
are shifting and you know, that when you're, when you're online,
you don't need a cashier. Um, so I mean,
it does affect real lives and, uh,
it's certainly efficient for the business owner,
but it's not great for their employees.
And that's why we need to look inwards and really make sure that we're taking
care of, um,
of everyone and especially our most vulnerable, um, throughout this process as,
as a shift happens. And I am optimistic that a shift can happen. Um, but,
but people need that peace of mind in order to just face it
in the first place.
Well, yeah,
it's hard for the shift to happen if people can't put food on the table and like
are worrying about, um, paying next month's rent. Now,
I feel like square must give you one of the best dashboards into what's
happening to small businesses right now that most anyone has.
I just saw this study that said, uh,
they think that 30% of small businesses might shut their doors forever.
What are you seeing at square in terms of what's happening to local
entrepreneurs?
Our sellers have been super creative, uh,
in terms of like hacking the system and trying to figure out new ways of doing
things. So all of our restaurants shifted to curbside pickup and delivery.
Um, we had a bunch of salons who shifted towards, uh, doing,
uh, FaceTime based or zoom based, uh, style, constant consultations.
Um, so a lot of creativity is emerging, but you're right. There are a lot.
Of people that could use that right now.
[inaudible].
Hair grown everywhere.
I wasn't suggesting that Jack, I was just generalizing about us all.
It's so true. Um, but yeah,
so we are seeing a lot of creativity and I'm really optimistic about that,
but I mean,
the reality is that we're seeing a lot of people have to lay off all of their
employees. Um,
we're seeing a lot of folks who are sole proprietors who have to shut down
completely. Um, and, and for a lot of people, this is their dream. I mean,
this has been their dream for years and years and years,
and they worked so hard to build this up. Um, and it's just been,
it's been devastating. So we're,
we're doing everything that we can to support it, but there are limits to that.
And, um, one of the things I'm proud of is we were a vehicle for the,
for the BBP second round,
and we were able to get out over $500 million to our sellers, um,
next day, um, uh, weeks as incredible banks. Um,
and, uh, and it, it's,
it's just been amazing to see that lifeline extended,
but I don't ultimately think that's enough. We have to,
we have to figure out how these sellers will change their models. And, you know,
a lot of these things, um, some of these things will not reemerge, but some,
some will and just a different format. And that's what I'm excited to,
to help folks too.
That makes me so happy that square was actually a conduit for some of that PPP
money, because I was thinking about those food truck operators and nail salons,
and just thinking, how the heck are they going to access that money? You know,
it's like a lot of them don't have like a private banker they can call.
So the fact that someone them called you and actually got that money
actually makes me really glad.
Yeah. We had, um, uh,
over 500 million to about 60,000 sellers across the country in every,
every state. Um, and it was from sole proprietors.
I think about 40% of them were employers
and 60% were so proprietors.
Yeah. I mean, those, those are really, like you said,
they're living their dream. You know,
they had this idea for a small business and they go out on a limb and that's one
of the tragedies of this economic collapses, you know,
it's affecting the local entrepreneurs the most.
It's, it's also just such a massive part of our economy and every single economy
around the world, like it's over 51%.
The small business economy is over 51% of almost every national
economy around the world.
Yeah. It's the job driver to in, in our economy and every other economy, uh,
you know,
and you were seeing just the seriousness of this crisis led you to do something
that is singular in our entire country,
which is you've pledged $1 billion in philanthropy to a combination
of COVID relief, uh, helping girls and women and universal basic income.
And Jack, I got to say like, you see that headline.
I remember you texted me when you were announcing. And I was like, I got chills.
I told you, I was like,
that is the greatest thing I've ever seen because a billion dollars, um,
at the time it was reported to be something like 28% of your net worth. Uh,
you know, and, and so people look up and, and, you know,
if you're worth several billion dollars, which you are,
it's an unfathomable amount of money to the vast majority of people,
but then everyone can understand 28% of one's net worth.
Like what drove you to such a massive commitment that really is
a singular right now in our society.
Well, I, I, I think there are a lot of,
there are a lot of people doing things privately,
but I thought it was important that we added more transparency to this
because a lot of these things tend to be fairly dark and invisible
and you don't really see the impact. And, um, we,
we launched this with a Google sheet, um,
which was just kind of a fast tacky way to do things, but the intention was.
It was very Jack Dorsey by the way.
Was not, not only to show where we're giving each,
each row has the amount and the org and their mission
and what these funds will go towards and also a link to their website for,
for people to, um, to click into and learn more or contribute themselves.
So not only to track what we're doing, but also to learn, like we,
aren't going to make mistakes in this.
And I want to make sure that we can annotate this sheet and just show people
where on why we made those mistakes.
So I thought that transparency was really important. And the other,
I think creative thing that we did is, um,
I'm not a liquid billionaire. I have equity in these two companies.
Um,
and I moved the square equity of billion dollars worth at that at that
day to an LLC.
And that LLC then gives it to adapt over time.
Uh, DAP is a donor advised fund. So the cool.
Thing is that, um,
the original billion I get I gave in the OSC is now worth 1.5 by.
Already. That's incredible. We did.
Move 200 million into the Def and they sold it on the market and we now have
200 million of cash to, to work with. And, um,
we've, we've now, um, we've now granted over 86 million,
um, of the, of the 200 so far where we've been able to move fairly fast,
but a lot of, a lot of it has been due to the incredible work that, uh,
existing foundations already have. I don't want to build a foundation.
I don't want to create a bunch of overhead and when all the money to go to the
people that need. So it's only two people it's myself. And, um,
my, uh, my assistant, such as chief of staff, uh, staff of Vanessa,
we want to keep it fairly light, um,
and really directed on these three problems of COVID response,
girls' health and education. And then, uh, universal,
basic income experimentation.
I have to say, that's the leanest thing anyone's ever heard of in philanthropy,
two people, two people, a Google doc, uh,
a billion dollars. Um,
and we're going to use this occasion in to make an announcement, uh,
which is that I think humanity forward actually is making that Google doc,
the coolest Google doc in the world.
Yeah, yeah. We're, we're, we're doing a,
we're doing 5 million for humanity for it and your work. Um, and, uh,
and, um, I, I just, I really appreciate, um,
who you are first and foremost, but also what you're doing.
I think this idea is long overdue.
And I think the only way that we can change policy is by experimenting and
showing case studies of why this works and a number of other countries have
proven small experiments as well, but we have to do it here. And, um,
I just, your, your voice, uh,
and bringing this to the public conversation and a global public conversation
has been incredible.
And I'm just so grateful because we need this and we,
we need this as soon as possible.
Well, thank you, Jack. I can't tell you how much I appreciate that.
And I can tell you exactly where the $5 million is going to go.
Um, we are going to give it to people, uh,
just sort of taking a page from your book.
We're going to just turn around and distribute micro grants of generally
$250 to thousands of people that you will make possible.
Um,
so I can't tell you how grateful I am personally and how grateful everyone who's
going to be benefiting from this gift will be because I
see the requests we get and they are Legion and
heartbreaking. There's just so much need around the country right now.
And we we've been in a situation where we've raised and distributed
a 1.5 million or so a little bit more, uh,
but this 5 million is a godsend and is going to change thousands of lives.
Um, so I can't tell you how much this is going to mean to so many people.
Hello.
Everyone. When I was running for president, we mailed a lot of stuff. Uh,
and so what we did is we went to stamps.com and bought one of those cool scales.
We had them in the office,
it became this freaking post office out of the office that I have to say gave me
some real pleasure every time I passed it, because, uh,
I'm a big believer in mail in a post office.
I think the fact that we're talking about the post office going out of business
is nonsense.
It's like the purpose of the government is to fund stuff exactly like the post
office. Now, when you want stamps, uh,
you can go to the post office or you can just go to stamps.com,
which is what we did. And that was a home run for us right now,
listeners to yang speaks get a special offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale without any long-term commitment.
So if you mail lots of stuff, this is your chance to just go to stamps.com,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in yang,
that stamps.com enter yang.
I, I want to give up, I want to give out all my money in my lifetime.
I want to see the impact, um, selfishly in my lifetime.
And I want to make sure that we're, we're helping people.
That's a good kind of selfish jacket.
And I wanna see, I wanna see that, that impact. And that's just like, I mean,
when you, when you build something like a Twitter or square,
that the greatest value is actually seeing someone else use it,
that's what drives us. It feels electric. I mean,
the first time that we saw tweets from Iran,
it felt electric. It felt amazing.
The first time we saw like one of my favorite coffee stores in San Francisco
using square and choosing it themselves.
That would be fine. Just walk in. Do you share,
they didn't choose it because they recognize you.
Um, positive. And then in the,
even better is when my mom went into her favorite coffee store that is Louis
and she saw it there and she texted me. And, um, so like that,
that electricity that I feel in those moments is the same that I'm feeling right
now when I give.
And when I know that these orgs that we're giving to are focused
on giving real impact and doing things that are bigger than all of us,
uh, and especially me. So, um,
I just want to learn as quickly as possible and how to do it the right way,
knowing that I'll make mistakes. Um,
and knowing that I'll have a ton of advice coming at me because this spreadsheet
is open. And, um, and, and that's, that's great.
And I know exactly where your money's going to go,
where we're concerned that like every dollar is going to go into the hands of a
struggling American family. And it just like,
like you're giving us the ability to,
to have that kind of impact on people's lives. Really.
I cannot tell you how grateful I, like, just like,
as a human being. I like, I just, it's beyond words really,
because without someone like you making this kind of move,
then we're just faced with the need. Um, and like, and, you know,
and then looking at the need and like, you,
you have to have confidence that you're going to get resources, uh,
but you don't know. And then because of you now,
we're going to have these resources.
I just hope that other people follow your example and want that same feeling
that you just described. Jack. I hope so.
I've had that feeling too. Um, and it, it's awesome.
Like people called me the Asian Oprah for a little while on the trail,
and I wasn't even doing that much,
but thanks to you, we're going to be able to do a lot more.
And I think there's a real appetite for universal basic income right now because
of the magnitude of the changes that we're.
A hundred percent. And also because of your voice, I mean, you,
you did put this on the national stage and, you know, it's been an idea that's,
that's talked about in this country since Martin Luther King, and maybe,
maybe before that, but, um,
you really reminded us all of the importance of it.
And what I appreciated about you so much is that you S you,
you were talking about the problems of the future. That we're not,
we're not addressing enough right now.
Like we only have so much time to address these things. And, um, if,
if the small steps we're taking today compound into experiments
that change and inform, inform, and change policy success,
I mean, that's awesome. And, and the more we can do in this space, the better.
Yeah.
It's one of the frustrations I have is that we've committed 2.8 trillion or so
at least Congress has, uh, towards relief in various forms.
And right now there are other bills, um, being proposed, uh,
and let's call it $3 trillion. That'd be like 10,000 a person. Um,
I can't help, but think that most Americans,
if you gave them a choice between 10,000 a person,
and then a whole host of other things, like we would probably choose, uh,
direct relief because we're like, well, I know I'll get it.
And I know that my neighbor will get it.
I agree. I mean, like it,
it's just a tragedy to see this money going to the banks and larger
companies, um,
when it could be going into the hands of individuals in this country.
And they like giving people money and trusting them
to do the right thing will have positive impact. It will.
And I think that the case against UBI in the, in the past has been,
you can't just give everyone money because it was just wasted. No,
that's not the case.
Like it will have positive impact and they will do the right things that are
incentivized the right things, but we need to,
we need to trust our people and we need to trust the people of this country and
other world.
Just such a pleasure, Jack. Uh, you know, I,
I feel honored to be having this conversation with you in this time of need for
so many, um, and your role model to more than, you know, I mean, really like,
uh, just knowing that you are you and doing what you're doing,
like makes me and other people feel like amazing things are possible.
We can eradicate poverty,
we can turn this crisis into something that actually accelerates positive change
as well as negative. Um,
we can build a better way of life and you're going to be an enormous leader in
that way.
And it's been an honor to talk to our future president.
Well, thank you for saying so, man, um, yeah. The future matter of time.
Well, thank you. I appreciate it.
And I appreciate your support during the campaign to, uh, like that,
that meant a lot at the time. Um, and, uh, yeah, we'll be back at it, you know,
uh, like the gang gang will be there and.
We'll be happy to be so happy.
I can't wait to meet your mom. I saw her tweets. She's like,
does that make me like the grandma Twitter, the dad,
she has quite a rambunctious grandchild.
Yeah. She shaved you off more than, than she was bargaining for.